- (laughter) That was so awful.
Sometimes I wish I could just disappear.
(upbeat music)
- To be honest, it looks
like I'm wearing both
for the rest of my life.
- I'd go with the tights.
That cape's just got to be annoying.
- I have great thighs
so I would rather wear tights.
- Tights, easily.
Tights are very comfortable,
it's like second skin.
- Well that's you, I'll take the cape.
(upbeat music)
- Black Widow.
Oh, I don't even know what
the rest of the question was,
but if I get to choose
having to deal with somebody,
it's Black Widow.
- I'm taking both, because
the more the merrier.
- I think they both would be great.
- I think I would bring Black Widow home.
She'd probably be easier to explain.
(upbeat music)
- I don't know.
Are those all euphemisms
for what's gonna happen?
- I know right.
- (laughter) I gotta say Wolverine's claws
because the other one doesn't sound right.
- Oh god.
- I'd rather be tickled
by Wolverine's claws.
I don't want no other man
rubbing me with his hammer.
- Tickled with Wolverine's claws,
if he hadn't had caffeine that day.
(upbeat music)
- I like to travel so
I think I'd like to go
and check out Asgard.
- Stark Tower.
- Stark Tower it's like
the pent house life.
- Stark Tower?
- Harlem, oh, Stark Tower.
(upbeat music)
- Well Ant-Man because
I feel like Spider-Man,
in our film anyways, is so
young that would be creepy.
- Man, that's tough.
Ant-Man, at least he can drink.
(upbeat music)
- I would rather be stuck on
a deserted island with Vision,
because I just love purple.
- Scarlet Witch, she can do
that stuff and like catch fish.
Zing.
Bonzino.
- I'm gonna say the Vision
just cause he might be able
to fly me out of there.
(upbeat music)
- The Hulk because the Hulk
can bust out of anything.
- Loki because I'd get really
claustrophobic with the Hulk.
- I don't think he would fit.
He probably wears a lot of cologne anyway.
- The Hulk?
- No, Loki.
- Loki. Elevator with the Hulk
you're almost guaranteed to die.
(upbeat music)
- I would rather be invisible.
I think you have a lot of opportunities
to get into mischief.
- I think being invisible
might be a lot of fun.
- I'll go invisible
because there's times in my
life I wish I were invisible.
(laughter) That was so awful.
Sometimes I wish I could just disappear.
(upbeat music)
- So I could see through anything?
- [Voiceover] Yes.
- Yes, that one.
- X-ray vision, it's gonna
be boring in an hour.
- I would rather have x-ray vision
- I would rather have super speed.
But are we talking about the drug or?
I know what you meant.
I'll still take the drugs.
(upbeat music)
- It's hard to judge, man.
I would rather be on team Iron Man.
- I'm gonna say team Cap.
- I would rather be on team Cap.
- Black Widow's on team
Iron Man, so let's do it.